it's on a Monday in the middle of the
pandemic although this [ __ ] here people
are ignoring it now you see what's going
on at California Michigan no people are
just saying that [ __ ] it we don't care
anymore the cops are running around
trying to arrest him and then just
there's just too many damn people people
said [ __ ] it
I saw one guy get arrested on here at
the you know that Disney park that's
like on an island but it was like
abandoned some guy was trying to camp
out on there yeah is all going this is
all going as Nostradamus has foreseen
I've told you that this would happen you
can moralize it and say it's right or
wrong it still doesn't matter these
people do what they want to do they
don't care what you think and it will
continue to be this way
what do you think Jenny yeah problem
that's oh yeah well you know people just
do it the [ __ ] they want to do doesn't
matter who they are do what they want to
do the people to bottom do what they
want to do people in the middle do what
they wanted everybody does whatever the
[ __ ] they want to do
contrary to what they're trying to
convince you everybody does remember the
[ __ ] they want to do so what's up Jenny
would you back what do we got well gosh
not a lot I know it's like I said I've
been working on like a game [ __ ] today
website been working on my book a little
bit um oh I watched something that they
newly added on shudder last night if
you're into like slasher movies and [ __ ]
like that they just added a documentary
about Kane Hodder yeah who if he didn't
know who that is he's the guy that
played Jason Voorhees in seven eight not
seven eight nine and maybe ten so forth
right Friday the 13th movies he was also
in the hatchet movies he's been in like
[ __ ] tons of other like kind of like the
best Jason
well yeah it's most kind of intimidating
Jason because I feel like well Jason
didn't really get played by the same
actor yet many times and if you look at
Jason from Part two he's not even a big
guy yeah
he jumps on one there's one scene where
he comes to a window jumps on one dude
he do t jump songs a lot bigger than him
yeah although you know he's crazy and he
has a bag on his head
doesn't actually work that way though
but now it was an interesting
documentary it really was out of him
getting burned up and then him trying to
bring that character to life and a lot
of sin you know and how he and he did a
good job and the eosin was in a bunch of
other movies so we have a scene we got
to see him I haven't seen any of the
hatchet movies there's three of those
[ __ ] movies now
he also played BTK yes that was another
thing like he played like he's played
serial killer a couple of times but he
was in the movie there about BTK or one
of the movies about BTK I'm sure there's
more than one [ __ ] hand satchel
problems yes oh my god you sexual
problems you know but you know bind
torture and kill it's the X Factor
yeah [ __ ] a douche he's cubing he
really is man but yeah so it's really
good if you're really into like slasher
movies and you're interested in Kane
Hodder and stuff I don't think it's it's
not quite as good as the Tom Savini one
and one thing that I will complain about
is that the background music during some
of the interviews was loud and it was
like almost drowning out the that might
even my sound system maybe if I have a
bunch of settings for different could be
yeah there might be admit might have
been optimized for a different mix yeah
probably yeah but yeah I didn't know all
that [ __ ] about [ __ ] Kane Hodder
getting like mostly [ __ ] almost burn
to death it was 22 and he's just like he
set himself on fire yeah cuz he was a
stunt man you know and he was like doing
it for for a newspaper story then he's
like whoops I did it Rob yeah a test
stories about what he did when he was a
kid yeah it's like do you think he was
constant getting his ass beat and how he
can't you know he's talking about you
know bullying and everything and they
were beating his ass he was a kid he
wasn't fighting back and then when he
wouldn't fight back they would just kept
they kept escalating it until eventually
he started swinging back and even though
he's still got his ass kicked
eventually they stopped trying to beat
him up because they realized wouldn't
wasn't worth it
yeah cuz he would fight back you know it
just goes back to what I was telling
what I've said many times before during
the show you know you can't give
anything for free you know
pacifism and pacifism and being weak is
a poor life choice because many people
in this planet especially young boys are
doglike creatures they're pack animals
and they what are you doing kid I got
these weird ass hormones and they do
weird [ __ ] when they see weakness they
[ __ ] they're like dogs they run after
it
if you like you can run from a dog a dog
will chase you a lot young boys are like
that if you look scared they'll attack
yeah they're not known for intelligence
you know they're dumb yeah Domon and and
they have just weird hormones in them
that do that so it's it you know
weakness is a poor life option somebody
attacks fight that just go down fighting
it's really weird because I didn't
realize that Kane Hodder was that
I mean he's he was unrecognizable like
from now from when he was a kid I mean
when he was a kid he was like really
small and like thin and even up until he
was like in high school and [ __ ] he was
like just this like real tall skinny
kind of dude and I wouldn't have guessed
that that was the same guy cuz now he's
like all [ __ ] bulked out and in my
experience a lot of years and my
experience a lot of those guys that
[ __ ] grew to be huge and we're real
aggressive got that way to defend
themselves from [ __ ] bullies yeah
well you can understand that's how you
become that although everybody says like
from the cons and everything like that
that he's like the nicest dude
everything and they even [ __ ] is ooh
it was funny because they had a Bruce
Campbell they had other people and
they're like Robert Englund and stuff
like that like talking about him but
they had a bruce campbell on there and
he said the funniest [ __ ] ever he said
something i've learned he's like you
know hanging out with kane hodder no the
other people like at the cons and
everything he's like I've met people
that played heroes and I met people that
played villains and he's like for some
reason the people that play heroes are
all [ __ ] yeah what the play villains
are always really nice guys one of the
one of the biggest kids we had in high
school he was a big big fearsome
[ __ ] this was back to when I was
in Trenton High and Michigan his name
was Eric and he was a hockey [ __ ] his
star I'm just dude is good enough he was
like gonna be a pro hockey player I
don't know if he ever got that way
he was probably the biggest strongest
kid in the high school but he was also
the most friendly he was a nice guy and
if if he ever saw
[ __ ] picking on like somebody was
totally defenseless he defended that
person that's good that's yeah a lot of
her like that yeah I mean well because
they don't have anything to prove that
right it's it's usually like the beta's
that are doing a lot of the attacking
like the betas of the [ __ ] tough guys
you know I said because they have
nothing to prove yeah they're trying to
try to compete with the guys that are
tougher than them and they really can't
do it so they just end up being dicks
yeah it's never the [ __ ] real jocks
that were doing a lot of the [ __ ] it was
it was like the betas of the jocks yeah
they were doing that [ __ ] like me and
Steve we weren't jocks we were [ __ ]
drama club they would call this drop
drama club [ __ ] the [ __ ] we hung out
with a real jocks a real jocks like this
yeah some of the you know more it's a
bad well they liked weed and they liked
girls they were we have that income they
had their [ __ ] no they had their [ __ ] we
had our [ __ ] you know yeah you know they
did do douchey [ __ ] yeah you know I mean
but we did cool [ __ ] make kind of new it
but it was like a little bit of
interplay but on that side of the fence
over there this is this is old
subcultures but on that side of the
fence it was like they're betas yeah
that were the foot ones the second the
second third tier do the ones that were
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] up they weren't
quite as popular right quite it's kind
of like this kind of like those guys
from that Heather's movie we saw dude I
was just gonna make those because that
was um that was the other thing that I
watched like after I was watching the
Kane Hodder thing and then I was like oh
I remembered about Joe Bob having his
weekly show now so like he does one
every Friday and it's just like just one
movie and he'll like talk about it
in-between and stuff and one of the ones
that he did like recently was Heather's
and I've seen that movie a million times
but I was like man [ __ ] it I was kind of
inebriated and I was like I just really
liked that movie and I want to hear Joe
Bob talk about it so I got to watch it
again I probably have that [ __ ] movie
memorized to be honest with you but yeah
it's like it's funny to me I guess I
didn't realize
until Joe Bob said this that when the
movie came out it was an 89 or 1990
because I know it was like right when I
was about to graduate high school
and he said it didn't really do very
well at the box office
which I thought was very weird because I
mean me and all my friends we thought it
was a [ __ ] riot we just thought it
was hilarious we saw it in the theaters
we quoted it each other we saw it like a
million times and it's like it's just
funny the way I don't know I guess dark
comedy is kind of a hard sell yeah and
um you know that movie is it's
essentially a comedy about teen suicide
and murder you know what I mean well I
remember I remember seeing it and and
kind of like in it yeah yeah I liked it
excuse me I only saw it only saw it VHS
you know you just see the theater and I
liked it but I wasn't crazy over it yeah
I did like Winona Ryder and Christmas
later in it yeah you know I mean I
thought those were cool characters but
that was about the extent of it I
thought the rest of the movie when I
when I was a kid yeah I thought the rest
of the movie was kind of like you know
not as good as say Beverly Hills Cop or
or Terminator or predator you know I
mean that's what you know when you're a
teenager you're more into that yeah you
know action well yeah action type movies
although I did it I did like it I just
didn't love it yeah evidently teen years
didn't like it according to the people
who made the movie except for me and
like everyone I knew yeah we loved it
but like I said it's it's a hard sell
making a comedy about us about topics
like that
and it goes it's pretty dark I mean
especially for back then I mean you
could probably get away with it now but
back then I don't know if you'd have
been able to I think a lot of the movies
that you and your friends like we're
[ __ ] movies like pretty in pink and
stuff like that I think they were those
who kind of like that the high school
chick flicks yeah all the guys didn't
like those that much yeah I mean we saw
anyway yeah yeah okay okay but then
immediately went on to something else it
was we liked escapist stuff yeah well I
liked that stuff too you liked it we
didn't like
I like all kind of different things yeah
we like to skate this to movies we
didn't want it movies about high school
that much although you know we don't
want what we did like though and I
remember we talked about was Breakfast
Club yeah we like to Breakfast Club yeah
I really like that movie too
well the character interaction is really
really good in that yeah we thought it
was good back then you probably saw it
now probably was kind of you know what
though because I saw it probably maybe a
year year and a half ago and I thought
it still held up really well I mean I
thought I haven't seen it forever
I mean some of the John Hughes ones not
so much did I I did watch Ferris
Bueller's Day Off not too long ago and
that was like still pretty funny and
like pretty charming and stuff but um
yeah I think I think Heather's holds up
really well and it's it was kind of like
ahead of its time because after that
they did all this [ __ ] with like Mean
Girls and all those kind of movies and
[ __ ] like that which I don't think they
would have done had Heather's not come
out prior to that and kind of busted the
wall up but there was a lot of them that
came out before that we used to see him
all the time on HBO and stuff then we
just see him lit and they were just so
cheesy I don't know what they're like
now but it like stuff like legend did
Billy gene yeah remember that [ __ ]
movie though it's really - I remember
that [ __ ] being cheesy even for back
then it was but I liked it I did yeah I
liked it but I knew it was cheesy but
how old were we like 12
probably yeah when the [ __ ] did that
come out 83 maybe some I remember that I
think that played right right around
like alongside [ __ ] Flash Gordon I
loved Flash Gordon yeah [ __ ] love it
but I remember really like Lou I I
remember like he said I likes legend a
Billie Jean but at the time it was even
even back then I was like fringe and
yeah just some of this and then they had
like a ripoffs of that what was the one
where we did a thing of the two dudes
from Israel came down here to make teen
movies and they didn't knew nothing
about American teens so just kind of
pulled it out their ass and all the
girls were getting abortions and hanging
out in malls and [ __ ] they played that
[ __ ] hey never that one we saw a
[ __ ] hole and we saw a whole like I'm
not talking about Fast Times at
Ridgemont High
no after it was supposed to be a rip
and it was it was by that studios that
did that just [ __ ] [ __ ] ripoffs like
battle beyond the stars and [ __ ] it was
those guys
this dude was two Israeli guys [ __ ] came
down here I can't think of it just came
here instead it set up a studio real
quick there were so many like teen sex
comedy basically what it was
teen sex comedy and but these guys
didn't know anything about American
culture American teens and it was like
it was like something from another
[ __ ] universe it was what is what they
thought American tree yeah I gotta
remember the name of it somebody
somebody out there might remember what
I'm trying to say though one of one of
the best teen of movies that I think is
like really underrated and doesn't get
talked about a lot is better off dead it
with John Cusack the one that I'm
talking about actually has to do from
color out of space out of it Mandy
what's his name Nicolas Cage it's got
Nicolas Cage in it Nicolas yeah it's not
valley girl you haven't seen that no I
don't yeah I saw it I'm talking about it
I [ __ ] saw it and he was probably
like about 17 or 18 like a 17 or
anything it might have been Nicolas Cage
his first movie hmm but valley girl
wasn't cheesy though I mean it was
cheesy but not I'll it was good that
what studio did that you remember no I
don't remember okay I haven't seen a
long time but it had a kick-ass
soundtrack man had Psychedelic Furs and
modern English and sparks and all that
kind of [ __ ] on it that might be it no
no I was like get an abortion in that
one no I'm pretty okay then it's not
that one I don't remember this one had
just one the only abortion one I could
think of as Fast Times at Ridgemont High
it was a ripoff of Fast Times at
Ridgemont High how many [ __ ] teen sex
how many's had abortions in them yeah
they show her going to the clinic and
[ __ ] putting her [ __ ] feet up on a
damn stirrups and [ __ ] she was crying
and [ __ ] I remember it I remember I'm
not saying you're lying I'm not very
good I think no was it it may have been
[ __ ] Nicholas Cage was in the movie
might have been somebody like Scott Baio
yes I was like I don't remember Nicolas
Cage not again Scott Baio I had a
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] like that he was in
it wasn't even that movies that was it
called zapped or something that was like
this was like 1982 that I'm talking
about
maybe 83 but 82 83 around that time
we're trying to figure this [ __ ] almost
live cuz I put these up only like
somebody out there might know what it is
I'm talking about now I have to look it
up cuz now I'm sitting there going it
sounds kind of familiar but this audio
is notorious for like doing [ __ ] just
terrible [ __ ] ripoffs hmm okay well
I'm gonna look it up they ended up going
broke eventually after we're only
they're only in business for about 10
years but anyway I was gonna say if
you're into like eighties comedies
there's two brothers I think the two
brothers from Israel
okay moved to LA and moved to Hollywood
and set that studio up
they made probably about 20 or 30 movies
and that was it and they were science
fiction movies teenage movies like in
action movies man if I saw the logo I
could pick it out of a crowd it's not
golan-globus was it no it was bad it was
like almost I know I know it wasn't the
people that did like Death Wish 4 or 5
but it was like that kind they would
then they'd be like the kind of people
that would do Death Wish 5 like cannon
or something like it worse yeah so might
have been cannon no cannon die think did
some good ones too didn't it yeah a lot
of their stuff was like shitty like
cheap but some of their shoe maybe it
was cannon yeah my Ben cannon cuz they
did end up going bankrupt later on I
think it was like it could have been
cannon yeah seriously if you like
eighties teen comedies and you haven't
seen better off dead with John Cusack
you need to see that [ __ ] because that's
that's a really really good one it's not
because it's not like zany it's weird
you know what I mean yeah it's it's it's
got like a [ __ ] hamburger that comes
to life and like sings van Halen songs
and it's like it's [ __ ] hilarious
[Laughter]
they got heat the same guy also made
one crazy summer which is also good
although I didn't like it as much as
better often okay so you ready - yeah I
just have to go see what that movie is
now but yeah I figured out now I have no
[ __ ] idea what yeah I'm just I have
to be reminded of it yeah it might have
been a canon film I mean I'm sure I've
seen it cuz I saw pretty much everything
back that like it had a cute cast but
the [ __ ] story was [ __ ] nuts okay
yeah now I'm curious alright I gotta go
look that [ __ ]
alright you guys have rescued good rest
of your Monday and we'll talk to you
again tomorrow